[موسيقى] أجنبية
نريد مساعدة الأشخاص على القيام بالأشياء
التي يريدون القيام بها وأحد
أهم جوانب الحياة هو
القدرة على التنقل من مكان إلى
آخر تحت قوتك الخاصة
[الموسيقى] ،
لذا فإن الهيكل الخارجي  في الأساس
حذاء عادي
بقطعة تمتد بطول
غطاء رأسك ومزود بمحرك وهذا المحرك
يلف كابل للمساعدة في إطلاقك
وأنت تمشي
[موسيقى]
إحدى الميزات المهمة هي أننا
نخصص المساعدة لكل
شخص وهكذا  هذا يعني أننا نسير جميعًا بشكل
مختلف ونحتاج في الواقع إلى
أشكال مختلفة من المساعدة لمعرفة
هذه الفوائد لرؤية هذا
الحد من الطاقة
[الموسيقى]
يعاني العديد من الأشخاص من إعاقات تجعل
ذلك صعبًا للغاية ويتباطأ الجميع مع
تقدمهم في السن ويجدون
المشي أكثر قابلية للتطبيق لذلك نحن
نعمل على تطوير الهياكل الخارجية التي تجعل
المشي سهلًا وسريعًا لنا جميعًا
[موسيقى]